it came out and i have to ask what
exactly is going on
well katie i think i made the perfect
chocolate chip cookie recipe
but i'm having issues with portioning
and ensuring each cookie will
bake and taste the same i mean the dough
looks pretty good itself i'd love to get
the recipe but as for portioning
i have some tools here that might be
able to help you get consistency with
each cookie
oh that would be great
[Music]
i didn't know you were an amateur baker
as well as being a software dev
that's right when my code is done i turn
it over to the customer
they then deploy it in their cloud
project according to
a long list of instructions that i've
written
but the problem is that these
deployments often turn out like my
cookies
uneven and not very good
that does stand frustrating yeah
it makes the customer unhappy and makes
me look bad
i know my code is correct but if it's
deployed incorrectly
it won't work have you considered using
an infrastructure as code tool instead
of your documentation you could write it
all as code
then you get repeatable deployments in a
machine-readable language
oh sounds great what's the tool
there are several but one that's widely
used right now is called terraform
it supports many major cloud platforms
including google cloud
let me give you an example of some of
the benefits of infrastructure as code
this gcloud command will create a cloud
storage bucket
for you but if you run it again you'll
get an error that the bucket already
exists
you could add manual checks around this
command to ask if the bucket already
exists and create it if it doesn't
but when you start adding these checks
around all your scripts it gets complex
and unmaintainable
so with terraform i won't have to write
so much shellcode
exactly in terraform you describe your
desired state a bucket exists in your
project
applying the terraform manifest will
check if the desired state has been met
if the bucket already exists terraform
will take no action
if the bucket doesn't exist terraform
will take the steps required to create
it
but what if i have things that are
different between deployments
like google cloud project id you write
terraform manifests in hcl hashicorp
configuration language
which allows for such complexities like
variables and calculated fields
terraform will also work out the
dependency graph itself when working
with multiple resources
some resources have to be created before
others
and some resources create data that will
be used by other resources
for example if you have a cloud run
service that relies on a cloud storage
bucket
the bucket has to exist first and
terraform will work that out
if you have say a deployment of five
cloud run functions that are independent
of each other
terraform will run those creations in
parallel which will be much faster than
creating each of those one by one
can i configure other google cloud
products with terraform
of course it isn't just limited to
serverless products
with the google terraform provider you
can deploy virtual machines
networking and other complex
infrastructure that would be downright
annoying and
frustrating to have to manually deploy
over and over again
oh nice so could terraform also help me
with setting up
test environments i mean sure
just consider what needs to be different
in test
you may want to add some variables to
say create a smaller cloud sql instance
rather than a production spec one but
with terraform you can easily create
duplicate setups
much like a cookie cutter in your baking
adventures
that sounds great can i also tell
terraform to build my containers well
terraform deploys existing assets like
containers or compile code it presumes
these resources already exist there are
a couple of ways that you can get around
this
you could have your existing artifact
creation process and then manually run
terraform when required that works well
if like you said you deliver your code
to a customer
or you can add terraform to your
existing automation for example as a
step in your cloud build configuration
this works well if you're doing in-house
development with continuous deployments
so i should convert the long list of
installation instructions in my readme
file to a teraform manifest
it's probably a good idea not only will
your deployments get more reliable
you can store your live infrastructure
configuration settings along with your
code and source control
i've left some links in the description
for you all right i will read up on that
so could you show me an example of a
terraform manifest for
serverless web application how about we
catch up next week and sit down
and work with some terraform code and
try deploying a few things
yeah that will give me a better idea of
how terraform works
let's do it great
[Music]